من الاحساء ينضم الينا مراسل صباح العربيه
عبد الرحمن العصيمي عبد الرحمن يسعد صباحك
هلا بهالطله من الاحساء
صباح الخير سهام واهلا وسهلا فيكي اولا
انا حقلب الايه اليوم وانا اللي حصل لك
اولا انت مع مين في كاس العالم وهل
اشتركتي في الباقه وجاهزتي البوب كورد
جهاز التيشيرت جهزت الاجواء في البيت ولا
لا لسه والله لسه يا عبد الرحمن
طب خليني اسالك طيب الاحساء يا عبد الرحمن
فيلم سهام الاستعدادات على قدم وساق نحن
اليوم في سوق القيصريه هذا السوق سهام
الذي تاسس عام 1822 ميلادي عمره تقريبا
حوالي سنه هذا السوق القديم الذي رمم اكثر
من مره حدث في حريق عام 2001 كان حزين جدا
لاهالي المنطقه لكن تم ترميمه لعل زميلي
المصور ناصر ياخذ بعض اللقطات كمان الشاهد
هذه البواب تحفه معماريه سهام كملوا شهاده
تفاصيل والفنون هي مزيج من الفنون
العثمانيه او طراز العثماني مع الطراز
الاحسائي او الحساوي كما نشاهد هذا السوق
فيه الممرات الضيقه والازقه تقريبا في
اكثر من 200 و 271 محل يملكها اهالي
الاحساء 251 عذرا والامانه او البلديه
تملك 77 محل في هذا السوق عام 2013 سهام
تم ترميم هذا السوق فكان يشاهد هذه الازقه
الضيقه هي من تميز هذا السوق هذا المكان
متوقع همم سهام ان يكون محطه رئيسيه لالاف
المشجعين والسياح القادمين والمتجهين الى
دوله قطر لحضور مونديال كاس العالم طبعا
هذا السوق يضم حرف يدويه كثيره صناعه
البوشود صناعه النعل الزبيري الرز الحساوي
همم الاشياء التراثيه كلها موجوده في هذه
المحلات الصغيره التي ربما بعضها يتجاوز
عمره اكثر من 200 عام مساحه هذا السوق
سهام تقريبا 7000 متر مربع تقريبا
ويعتبر قبل سنوات كان هو اكبر سوق شعبي
خليجي لكن الان مع تطور اللي صار في كثير
من المدن تغير هذا السوق همم اكثر اكثر
جميل سهام اهل الحساء متعودين على السياح
متعودين على نعم تفضلي اهل بس يا عبد
الرحمن والحسى تحديدا معروفه بانها مدرجه
على اليونسكو بسبب معالمها التاريخيه
المبهره الى اين مدى فرصه المونديال هي
فرصه كذلك للاقتصاد بهدف انعاش تراث
واقتصاد هذه المنطقه المميزه
والله يا سهام اذا قلت لك اذا قلت لك يا
سهام منه اهل الحساء متحمسين للمونديال
اكثر من اهل قطر
فيها مقومات
[ضحك]
مع انك ما قلت لي المنتخب بسالك لكن
الحساسه ميزه ميزاتها اهلها ههه بعد
الهواء نحكي فيها هذه لكن الميزه انه اهل
الحاسه متعودين على السياح من زمان يعني
هي محطه رئيسيه للخليج كلها حتى لو
تلاحظين الاهالي متزوجين من همم من العراق
من قطر من الكويت من البحرين همم بالاضافه
طبعا الى انه هذا السوق كان محطه رئيسيه
كمان يشاهد البيوت الطينيه الجميله
والرائعه هذه في سوق القيصريه بالاضافه
الى طبعا العديد من المحلات ومن
المقومات السياحيه هناك ايضا المشاريع تم
افتتاحها
خلال الفتره الماضيه مشاريع سياحيه
لاستقبال السياح محافظ الاحسان ان شاء
الله سنتقي به هذه الايام للحديث اكثر عن
المشاريع السياحيه الى جانب ايضا سهام
النزل الفندقيه يعني هل الحساء صراحه بده
يحاولون منازلهم الى نزل فندقيه لتاجيرها
طبعا الليله اسعارها طبعا دبلت اكثر من
مره لانه هذا يعني حدث تاريخي لا يحدث في
المنطقه الا نادره عبد الرحمن
بيوتهم
وشوقتني بس انا يا عبد الرحمن
عبد الرحمن صباح الخير يعني الحقيقه همم
ما في حدا يعني يقدر هالقد يسوي قدك انت
يا عبد الرحمن
تسلمين ميسون وانت بعد ما يصون ابنك لعيب
كوره على ما اذكر فان شاء الله مونديال
القادمه
[ضحك]
فرنسا فرنسا